so this video is mainly for the beginner
someone that is
just starting intermittent fasting i had
a question recently
regarding the five and two um diet
which basically is what i think is the
worst
intermittent fasting pattern and then in
this video i want to talk about
some really good intermittent fasting
patterns now the whole purpose of this
is to achieve
the massive benefits of fasting
without the negatives like loss of
muscle nutritional deficiencies so let's
start with the worst in a minute fasting
pattern
it's called the five and two diet it's
also called the fast diet
and this is how it works so for five
days you're gonna eat your
normal foods whatever that means
and then for two days you're gonna go on
a low calorie diet
500 calories per day now to me this is
not even fasting
it's really a combination between eating
junk food for five days and then for two
days you're restricting your calories
now if you're going to do two days each
day being 500 calories and it's
keto foods you're going to experience
some benefits
but here is the big problem it takes
three days
to actually get into ketosis so by the
time the two days are up
you barely have gotten into ketosis and
if you haven't gotten the ketosis you're
gonna be
suffering you're going to be craving
carbohydrates you're going to be hungry
it's going to be very very difficult but
you're going to lose some water weight
initially and you might think wow this
is working it's helping me lose weight
and then you can go back to your normal
regular foods for the next five days
so from my viewpoint the five and two
diet is the absolute
worst all right the next worst pattern
which is maybe slightly better than the
five and two is what's called the
alternative day
fasting in which you would eat what you
want
on one day and then the next day you do
a 500 to 600 calorie
diet so you go back and forth and back
and forth but remember it takes three
days to get into ketosis so you really
are not even scratching the surface so
you may create
some benefits but number one it's not
sustainable
and you're not going to even be close to
achieving
the benefits that you should be
achieving so let's switch over to
the best patterns so the 18 and six
where you're fasting for 18 hours
and then you're eating within a six hour
window so let's say for example your
first meal is at noon and your second
meal is at
6. that would be a good 18-6 pattern now
if you want to achieve more benefits you
go to the 20 and 4
which i really like so your first meal
is at 2
and then your second meal is at six
giving you
20 hours of benefits from fasting
now if we want to take it one step
further you'd want to do
one meal a day it's called omad and a
lot of people do this
especially if you're over the age of 50
with
amazing amazing benefits so if you're
new to my channel i put some links down
below so you can learn how to do this
correctly because
when you're doing omad you want to make
sure that you're definitely doing
certain nutrients because if you have
any potential subclinical
deficiencies going into eating one meal
a day
you know you could have some issues all
right so what does all this magic that
happens at 18 hours or 20 hours
number one you spike growth hormone
which is anti-aging
number two you increase what's called
autophagy so now you're actually
tapping into an anti-aging condition
where your body is recycling
old damaged proteins and you're starting
to extend your life
number three your inflammation goes down
dramatically
so if you have arthritis autoimmune
issues
this is going to be very beneficial next
one is your immune system will start to
improve so you strengthen your immune
system
next one is you're going to lose weight
and i already mentioned you're going to
live longer by doing this
and the last two benefits which are
quite huge
is this number one your cognitive
benefits
your focus your memory your
concentration
will do better and your mood will do
better and so if you're doing the five
and two and the alternative day fasting
where you're grouchy all the time doing
the 18 and 6 or 24 or omad
you're going to be very very calm you're
going to feel serene
you're going to feel really good so i
challenge you
to give it a chance try it out start
with the 18-6
and just see how you do thanks for
watching
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help